how do you create adversity the proper  amount of adversity for your child so  that they grow  but not so that it's  like a ridiculous for them one of the  best things that you can do as a parent  is  let your child fail think it back on  your life and some of your failures end  up being the catalyst  for one significant amount of confidence  once you fail at something and you come  back around you study more you work  harder you train longer and then you  come back around and you and you pull it  off and you do it that is an integral  part of life because  things are not going to come your way  the first time and so it's learning the  ability to not take the initial failure  and knowing that you have the ability to  come around and get it no matter what